[Music]
hey guys it's justine and i am so
excited because today in front of me i
have the new microsoft surface laptop
studio running windows 11. now why i'm
so excited about this is because it's
basically taking one of my favorite
things the surface studio the actual
desktop that you can just take fold down
put in so many various configurations
and it's so
freaking cool and i felt like it was so
revolutionary at the time when they came
out with this this is such an
interesting combination between the
surface studio and the surface laptops
so i can't wait to try it out i did get
a little bit of hands-on time with this
at the microsoft lounge but now it is
here in my hands for however long i i
want to hold it so let's unbox it and
check it out
[Music]
look at you
oh boy
okay so here it is let's just take this
off
[Music]
instant on hello
what else do we have in here
we've got some
instructional papers
just put those back in there we've got
our power cable
oh yes can i help you hi
look at this getting things ready for me
i guess while that's happening we'll
open up our
slim pen too
this is a nice little
[Music]
packaging yes look we're set up we're
set up
oh my goodness this is the first time
that i'm actually getting hands-on with
windows 11 in my own personal space this
is exciting i am having like flashbacks
when i updated my pc that i had made in
high school
to
like windows 2000 like it was such a
crazy thing like it's here it's here
it's finally here 12k let's do it
and now
here we are
many many
many years later with windows 11. this
is really exciting
this is the surface laptop studio this
is microsoft's newest premium notebook
and even though it sort of borrows some
design features from microsoft's other
devices like the surface studio the
surface book and the surface laptop this
little hybrid device definitely stands
out on its own not only does it have a
fresh design featuring a new pull
forward display it has really powerful
graphics with an nvidia geforce rtx card
thunderbolt ports windows hello 2.0 and
a high refresh rate screen i think the
main thing that makes this surface
device so exciting is this new dynamic
woven hinge design which allows you to
use it in three different modes there's
laptop mode which arranges the device
like any standard laptop with a full
keyboard and the haptic trackpad stage
mode which is one of my personal
favorites allows you to pull the screen
forward to cover the keyboard and this
will put your content front and center
and then for studio mode you just push
the screen right down into the perfect
position for creative tasks like writing
or illustration the display is a 14.4
inch with 2400 by 1600 resolution and
support for dolby vision hdr there's
also the new surface slim pen 2 which is
actually stored right underneath the
keyboard now the pen doesn't come
bundled with the surface laptop studio
so if you do want to pick one up it will
set you back an extra 129.99
which might seem a little spendy but
this thing is so nice it has over 4 000
levels of pressure and a new haptic
motor that simulates the feel of inking
on various surfaces this really
surprised me how cool it was when i got
to test it out for the first time a few
weeks ago but now that i'm actually here
and have it in the studio just drawing
and writing and just using it is so
awesome you can tell with this device
and windows 11 that microsoft is really
focused on making teams calls
improvements a huge priority the depth
camera and facial tracking are now smart
enough to factor in beards glasses
masks and the 1080p front-facing camera
can now adjust the lighting on your face
so if you're not in ideal lighting
conditions you'll still be in focus and
well exposed they also improved the
audio experience they've added some
additional microphones so it'll pick up
your voice better and it also now
includes squad omnisonic speakers and
dolby atmos for clear conferencing audio
and music playback another thing that
really makes this device so exciting is
how powerful it is it uses the new tiger
lake h35 chip which intel just launched
this year you can get it with a quad
core i5 or an i7 but the i7 version will
ship with a geforce rtx 3050 ti so that
paired with the new dynamic refresh rate
feature is going to make this surface
laptop studio so great for gaming so the
price starts at 1599.99 and depending
upon your specifications of how you
configure the device it can range all
the way up to over three thousand
dollars i absolutely love everything
that surface has been doing recently
over the past couple of years so this is
no exception if you guys enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
make sure you subscribe so you won't
miss any other tech videos that i have
coming out it is still tech season i
can't wait there's so much more fun to
come if you guys have any questions at
all or anything that you'd like me to
test out in the future on this device
please leave it in the comments below
and i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
my
you